in my video about my malagor deck I
introduced the concept of counterweight
commanders these are commanders that
rather than directly synergizing with
the cards in a deck instead offset a
weakness of the deck that concept as
applied to that deck went roughly as
follows I knew I wanted a deck that
focused on grindy lowcost creatures and
discard spells grindy lowcost creatures
have the downside that they're small and
often easy to block and discard spells
have the downside that opponents can
choose to play their most valuable
creatures as fast as possible to avoid
losing them to discard by selecting
malagor as a commander the de always has
access to a tool that it can use to
clear out opposing boards mitigating the
downsides of the cards in the 99 the
cards in the99 likewise nullify maor's
weakness of making me hellbent by making
opponent lose cards as well and
providing ways of generating value that
stick around after my hand is gone so
here we have a deck where the commander
isn't directly related to what the deck
does but instead has a mutualistic
relationship with the deck meshing
together with it to form a cohesive hold
that benefits both commander and 99 now
this is undoubtedly the most elegant
version of a counter rate Commander
among my decks but in retrospect I think
that fact almost serves to obscure the
concept A bit a counter rate Commander
can look like that but it can also look
like a lot of other things so seeing as
how this is a subject that is
fundamentally related to my deck
building and how I haven't dedicated a
video to it outside of a little
five-minute thing in July of last year
I'm going to give the concept A full
discussion I'm going to discuss the
conceptual roots of it give some
additional examples and talk about how
it fits into the broader EDH ecosystem
as well as discuss some of the
limitations of of this style of deck
building to start with let's return to
the definition I gave earlier a counter
rate Commander is a commander that
serves to cover the weaknesses of a
given deck it's easy to imagine that
this is a revolutionary Innovation that
I came up with and have been employing
under the radar for years before finally
now spilling my secrets however the
truth is much more mundane fundamentally
the idea of a counter rate Commander
emerges naturally from the process of
rigorously interrogating what in exact
detail your command zone is offering you
in a given deck as Commander players
it's easy to slip into a mode of
existence where we forget the rules of
the format or rather where we calcify a
specific understanding of the commander
format in our brains almost all popular
commanders fall into one of two
categories they're an enabler for a
particular thing or more commonly
they're a payoff for a particular thing
decks are supposed to have one or more
themes and then a commander that helps
out with one of those themes a lot of
players internalize this as the way to
build Commander decks but this actually
misses a lot of the possibility space of
the format let's think about the
commander format as somebody who has
never heard of it before and is reading
the rules of the format you have a 99
card deck with only one of Any Given
card on the surface not great for
purposes of consistency compared to a 1
V1 format however this is bolstered by
an additional card that you always have
access to an eighth card in hand
effectively this makes the command Zone
a critical resource for any player
looking to maintain a level of
consistency in their deck one way to
utilize this is the ever popular payoff
card you can run Isen as your commander
to enhance the effectiveness of your on
attack triggers or will help to increase
the efficiency of your zombies these are
reasonable as they allow a deck builder
to focus most of their effort on these
sorts of cards knowing that even if
they're a little subpar alone these
cards are guaranteed to have a little
boost as long as the commander sticks
around however there are lots of other
things that a player might want to
guarantee and other ways that guaranteed
things can mesh into a game plan my high
power Francisco Malcolm deck is one that
tries to land a one drop pirate turn one
Francisco turn two and Malcolm turn
three and then uses Francisco's
filtering and Malcolm's Treasures to
curve into a turn five or six infinite
turns combo with time siiv now this is
not an example of a counter rate
commander and could even be considered a
conventional engine Commander my command
Zone generates resources given the input
of a key card type performing a specific
action Pirates dealing damage to players
however this is undoubtedly a more
intentional command Zone than your
typical build of something like Admiral
Becket brass even as it's similar on
paper Francisco guarantees that I have a
two drop available every single game and
Malcolm is a key piece of the deck's
combo and also guarantees a source of
available Mana for my 13 counters spells
even when my lands are tapped out as I
said this isn't an example of a counter
rate Commander but it involves a
similarly meticulous focus on what the
command Zone offers a player for a
similarly curve out oriented example my
R deck has the goal of playing R ER deel
on turn two as a Mador an explosive
vegitation analog on turn three and a
stream of cascade spells and six to
seven cost bombs from turn four onward
by fully covering my lowcost ramp R
allows me to have nothing below four
Mana in the 99 thereby strengthening the
Cascade cards and allowing for extremely
high top deck quality even with a land
count of 41 now this actually is an
example of a counter rate commander and
a wonderfully simple one at that I
identified that a turn two rata in the
command Zone could allow me to eliminate
the normally space hogging element of
lowcost ramp in a big Mana deck without
losing too much speed and then the rest
of the deck was constructed to further
take advantage of that choice if we
think about a commander deck as a stool
I basically removed one leg from that
stool and then shoved my commander under
there as a replacement making additions
from there with the fantastic ftic wood
savings I'd achieved curve out is almost
always a factor in my commander deck
building choices but it's not always
quite as dominant a factor as it is in
my R deck for a now somewhat deprecated
example of a counter rate Commander
let's talk about my glissa deck glissa
sunslayer is a three Mana 33 death touch
first strike that allows its controller
to choose between drawing a card
destroying an enchantment and removing
three counters from something whenever
it hits a player when I first saw this
card I noticed two things about it it
can offer a stream of draw and it's a
really good blocker what sort of deck
make use of a lowcost creature with that
sort of profile a greedy battle cruiser
deck of course a big Mana deck can
benefit from having an early utility
play guaranteed as this makes it
possible for a deck to focus more of its
space on higher costed cards while still
having early plays in addition the first
strike death touch pairing makes glissa
a fantastic blocker allowing the deck to
ward off early aggression a thing that
might otherwise cause problems for a
greedy late game deck I eventually
decided that my R deck scratches the
same itches as this one more effectively
but it's nonetheless useful as a case
study for weakness mitigation as another
example my leasa deck pairs a commander
who is good at deleting opposing life
totals with a 99 made up of lower cost
hate bears and utility creatures the
deck's hate Bears hinder opposing game
plans and slow down the pace of games
and liasa is here to be a reliable way
of cutting down life totals in that
slowed environment since she's a great
beater that is effectively immune from
Commander attacks in both of these cases
the Commander's Mana value is important
and they're often played when that much
Mana is available but they can be pushed
back a bit if the deck has a better play
overall this counterweight style of
Commander choice is a really fun one it
provides mechanically textured gameplay
and it also scratches my hips to itches
since it means that my decks are almost
always different from opposing decks
however this isn't a perfect method and
indeed can lead to some problems one
problem that can arise is that when the
commander is one of very few cards to
play a particular role in that deck that
deck's functionality can be greatly
hindered if the commander becomes
unavailable one example of this is a
Torsten deck I built several months back
it's a deck that's entirely creatures in
lands and which uses playing and
blinking Torsten as its only draw
effectively drawing seven cards per
Torsten entry upsides packs a lot of
draw into just a handful of deck slots
allowing space for a ton of ramp to
guarantee fast roll outs downsides oh
boy if this deck draws poorly or gets
its board wiped too early it can sit
around twiddling its thumbs for multiple
turns on end with all of its card draw
behind an imposing seven or nine Mana
barrier when this deck works it really
works but the play pad pattern can just
as often be jarring and awkward so this
is an issue that can come up with this
sort of deck building but for it to
cause problems as it did in this case
two things really need to be true for
one the deck needs to have no meaningful
backup quantity of the thing the
commander is providing my malagor deck
would really struggle if it didn't have
a way to clear out opposing boards but
it runs a decent removal Suite in
addition to the commander for that exact
reason including a handful of small
creature wipes intended to hinder token
players who might otherwise get out of
hand by contrast the ton deck has
literally no draw outside of the command
Zone due to how tight space in the deck
is unless you count Savala as draw
secondly the thing the commander is
providing needs to be a key requirement
for the long-term functioning of the
deck in order for there to be a problem
myata deck has absolutely no lowcost
ramp aside from R herself and as some
people have pointed out the commander
getting removed immediately does cause
me to basically skip my turn three but
this rarely happens because it's not
actually a particularly good usage of
removal this is an inevitability deck
not a Tempo deck and a one- turn setback
for a slower deck just isn't that big a
deal in midow EDH when V dies early I
shrug Garner a bit of table sympathy and
then proceed normally starting on turn
four by contrast my Torsten deck
requires constant access to him and any
barrier to utilizing him stonewalls the
deck's game plan the other potential
issue with counter Rec commanders is
that it can lead to Decks that some
might find a bit Bland in terms of card
Choice as you might have noticed earlier
I actually titled my original video on
this topic a weird trick to making cool
midr decks which certainly indicates
something it is true that a lot of decks
do end up moving somewhat in this
direction my glissa deck is a pile of
generic dudes my rat deck is a Cascade
flavored pile of generic dudes my liasa
deck is a lower curved and somewhat
staxy pile of generic dudes and if you
squint around the interesting bits my
malagor deck is also kind of a pile of
generic dudes this fundamentally comes
down to the nature of the strategy at
its core the counter rate Commander
method is all about rejecting direct
Synergy with the Commander in favor of a
game plan that meshes with the commander
indirectly ly in EDH broadly the
commander of a deck will often be a
central node to begin building the deck
synergies off of so without that direct
Synergy relationship it's easy to end up
grabbing best-in-class cards rather than
ones that perform a specific dynamic or
synergistic game plan this doesn't mean
that all decks with this method need to
lack Synergy my maore deck has a bit of
direct Synergy with self- discard and
some other Synergy packages that relate
to the sorts of game states that my
demon dragon friend promotes and my deck
likewise features a decent amount of
cascade as a natural offshoot from
having a commander that allows me to run
very few lowcost cards it's fully
possible to make interesting synergistic
decks within the bounds of this method
but it is undoubtedly more difficult and
I considered finding interesting
Dynamics and card choices within the
counter rate Commander framework to be
one of the fun challenges of the method
to cap off the video I'm going to give
one more example of a counter rate
commander deck that is something of a
deviation from the mid-range framework
and actually it was the first one I ever
built in 2019 I built a $25 budget combo
control orof Deck with Campbell console
allocation as the the commander unlike a
lot of common control commanders
Campbell doesn't help generate value or
control the board rather he's simply a
three Mana 23 that drains an opponent
for two points of life whenever they
cast a non- creature spell so what's he
here for well primarily life gain which
Campbell guarantees a near constant
source of now life gain isn't a
particularly useful thing on its own
life totals are a key factor for winning
the game yes but Tempo and value tend to
be more important contributors to the
winning and losing of games particularly
in a for like Commander where life
totals are high by default nor is this a
deck with much in the way of life gain
synergies affects the trigger when life
is gained so where does life gain fit in
here well for one control decks tend to
be weak to life total pressure so this
helps with that but life gain also helps
control decks in another way see in a
deck with a lot of board wipes opponents
will deploy creatures in tactical
numbers if a control player is at 28
life a mid-range player might choose to
drop maybe 10 or 15 power worth of
creatures on board knowing that that
number could threaten a control player's
life total without requiring too much
commitment however if that same control
player is at 44 life suddenly the
situation is trickier and the mid-range
player may be tempted into overcommit
into a board wipe this principle led to
a semi-ironic phrase becoming Infamous
in my play group controlling them with
your life total aside from this control
aspect it was also useful to have a lot
more life than opponents for purposes of
winning since most of the de wincons
hinged on sanguin bond paired with a big
life gain effect as a final bit of
utility Campbell disproportionately
hated out fiddly non-c creature-based
decks such as the pool's spells Slinger
deck and the pool's eggs deck this is
key because these sorts of decks
otherwise posed a major challenge to the
deck which focused on creature killing
and sorcery speed board wipes this deck
likely wouldn't Faire particularly well
outside the budget environment it was
born in but it serves as a good reminder
of what a single line of text can
accomplish in the right environment it
can smooth out bad matchups indirectly
generate value and help to close out a
game that's the biggest takeaway from
all of this the power of your commander
comes above all else from Context the
situation into which you're dropping
them from the command Zone arrange that
context just right and you'll find all
sorts of commanders performing Way
Beyond your initial
expectations thanks for watching and
thanks to architect for supporting the
channel I spend way too much time
fiddling around with decks and architect
does a great job facilitating that
through its streamlined UI and highly
visual presentation a link to my decks
is down in the description I'd also like
to thank my patrons some of whom are on
screen now I do monthly Deck review
videos where I go through and analyze a
hand full of Patron decks so if you want
a shot at getting your deck reviewed by
me a link to my patreon is down in the
description finally if you want more of
me without paying money I'm on a podcast
with the trinket beig and 33 elk there
should be an episode featuring Mal Hound
coming out around the same time this
video is and if you want to see that a
link will be in the description whenever
it's up all right bye now